I'm a man I'm not I'm not crying Doug
I'm cool straight the worst drink of my
life I think it's like tequila and
ginger ale
it's who made this Cheers
I definitely feel it yeah me too I feel
like an idiot let's go I have their cups
because I have their cups not because I
have the drunk pickups however yes I am
drunk and have the hiccups but I've had
the hiccups oh do I need to take my
lactaid pills my favorite gift under the
tree I am Jewish sister got a dog one
year
it's a beautiful wonderful puppy that I
love to play with growing up he always
had a cat which cats are fine but I love
dogs
I have fiancé loves dog today she posted
a video of 50 pugs running through the
front door of someone's house
[Music]
God if this buzz I'm gonna fight someone
like oh my god can I take it off this is
gonna be different than what I thought
this box is making noises like a dog do
we name them I haven't even looked at
them I just needed to touch them so
badly oh no you just got neutered oh
yeah don't drink my beer we get to keep
them right yes like that's deserves the
video that's what I was so this video
was originally supposed to be drunk guys
eat holiday foods okay okay get these
they're all it don't [ __ ] tell me
about you guys fooled us and the best
way possible I thought I was gonna get
the equation are we not getting to get
food to be here oh geez and I think that
if your kid wants a dog you know that's
a way to get them to love Christmas I
want to steal all of them right now do
not ever let this moment end my
Christmas oh they're playing